hello everyone bulkin here and today I'm
gonna do something that I'm probably
gonna be starting to do every weeknight
and that is called the SCP rhyme table
which is essentially all the scps that
i've done this week I'm gonna point to
them in this video if for any reason you
might have missed them which some people
probably did okay so the first SCP
themed video that I'd done this week was
scp-049 rule plant which basically is
scp-049 connects to a gmod rule playing
server as himself I'll let you find out
what happens I'll leave it as a surprise
the second one was my patreon video this
is the last time I'm gonna plug this
vocally but if you haven't seen the
video go and watch it please consider
being a patreon okay moving on the third
one is SCP 1836 mother in the ice now
this was the major SCP featured and Lord
bongs confinement episode 4 so this was
the first in my confinement celebration
series this week it's pretty interest in
SCP a lot of hard to prove there's a lot
of hard to pronounce words in it so if
you're offended by mispronunciation just
watch the video to laugh of it I guess
that's number three number four is SCP
174 ventriloquist's dummy as somebody
who is quite scared of dolls on dummies
like that this was kind of disconcerting
to read for me but again this is the
second in my confinement episode for
series so I've thought something you
would like go watch it on finally we
have SCP 422 finish the week if you're
not in a very serious mood go watch it
it's pretty much one of the most
well-known Jocassee peas ever so you've
probably heard of it but I think might
take on that's pretty good and I guess
the last thing I want to say is if you
haven't enabled the little bail next to
my subscribe button
ohdid because you'll get notified
whenever I post a video I'm aiming to
post at least three videos a week at
this stage so I'm constantly up Lewton
and I really want everybody interested
in scps
do you see it so if you do that that
would be amazing okay thanks very much
for listening and I will see you next
week where I will be creating scp-718
first one scp-914 and scp-2319 I get the
CPS for next week if you haven't
realized I'm seven scp-173 or my last
ever heritage collection SCP after the
Heritage Collection is done it will be
organized and committed into your
playlist and man I will be open for
full-blown suggestions of whatever you
want or suggestions for another
collection I have rambled on way too
much but thank you for listening I'm
gonna go bye bye have a great weekend
peace